les filles sont des bavards et leur
temps elles le passent à raconter leur
vie sur facebook évidemment les garçons
eux c'est plutôt jeux d'aventure et
d'action
on en vient maintenant à cette étude
concernant les adolescents et Internet
tous les parents et grands-parents vont
sans doute se sentir concerné regardez
d'abord ces chiffres l'étude montre qu'à
14 ans un collégien sur deux ils
consacrent plus de 3 heures par jour
alors faut-il s'inquiéter pour eux
faut-il sévir interdire ou tout
simplement encadrer Anne-Charlotte Tinet
Nora fadlaoui
c'est bien connu à 14 ans les filles et
les garçons c'est un peu comme le jour
et la nuit tous les opposés sur internet
le cliché ne se dément pas les filles
sont des bavards et leur temps elles le
passent à raconter leur vie sur facebook
évidemment les garçons eux c'est plutôt
jeux d'aventure et d'action
les jeux j'aime bien parce que déjà
c'est c'est gratuit et on peut en faire
autant qu'on veut quoi parce qu'il y en
a des milliers sur des milliers de
titres donc je peux en faire autant que
je veux illimité avec de toutes sortes
quoi c'est pour discuter avec mes amis
ou pour faire des recherches enfin des
fois des mêmes pour travailler pour ses
devoirs ou enfin pour se détendre pour
distraire une enquête sur 2000
collégiens a montré que les filles
passent 80% de leur temps sur Internet à
écrire à leur copine le reste du temps
elles écoutent de la musique les garçons
eux passent 40% de leur temps à jouer
30% à regarder des vidéos le reste à
aller sur des forums ou faire des achats
fille ou garçon nos ados y consacrent
tout de même beaucoup de temps 50% des
ados de 14 ans passent trois heures par
jour sur le net 3% seulement il reste
plus de 10 heures et le temps devant
l'écran c'est justement tout le problème
pour les parents
il faut faut arrêter appuyer sur le
bouton et quitter l'ordinateur et
toujours un peu difficile
donc c'est vrai que c'est une lutte
quotidienne quasiment restez scotché à
son ordinateur est-ce vraiment
inquiétant la réponse du psy beaucoup de
parents ont tendance à penser que si
leur enfant va beaucoup sur Internet
c'est qu'il s'isole et qui va pas bien
en fait ça se passe pas du tout comme ça
un jeune peut très bien aller beaucoup
sur Internet et très bien se socialiser
sur Internet notamment avec des
camarades d'école qu'il retrouve à
travers l'écran qui internet à la maison
l'ordinateur dans sa chambre à 12 ans à
peine la moitié de ses élèves de 5e à un
ordinateur dans sa chambre et c'est bien
cela qui peut poser problème les
infirmières scolaires nous le disent les
médecins scolaires le disent les
enseignants le disent ils ont des ados
fatigués qui arrivent le matin
effectivement avec des seins sous les
yeux les spécialistes sont unanimes une
seule solution pour les parents limiter
la consommation Internet de leurs ados
[Musique]